Many lessons ago, we've talked about how to develop the public interface of the
class, the methods that one might want to call on objects of the class. But
we've always pretty much given to you the instance variables, because it turns
out that picking the right instance variables isn't all that simple. While now,
the time has come for you to do more of that yourself. And I'd like to give you
a few rules of thumb, on how you might discover instance variables. To see how
those rules of thumb work, let's have another look at the Car class from Lesson
three. That class had an instance variable to hold the amount of gas in the
tank. That was a method to add gas where the parameter value would be added to
the gasInTank. Now the point that I want to make is that there is a certain
pattern here. You have a quantity here. Here you make that quantity bigger. It
also gets smaller when the car is driven. I like to call that pattern keeping a
total. And it occurs in many classes, not just the car. So then lots of times
we have some class and you have some variable, which may be called total or
not. And then there's some methods that add to the total. Maybe some methods
that clear the total, or subtract from it. I'll give you a few situations, and
I'll ask you whether the pattern of keeping a total applies. So, would you keep
a total to model the account balance in a bank account? Friends in a social
network? A car odometer? Stripes in a flag. Check all where you think the
pattern makes sense.